PROFESSOR: So as
a technical aside,
let me go through and sketch
the derivation of the structure
of a turbulent jet, in
particular the conical shape
that we have when the
flow is turbulent.
So in order to study
the mean flow profile
we began with the
Navier-Stokes equations
which describe the momentum
conservation and mass
conservation or continuity of
an incomprehensible so-called
Newtonian fluid.
So this is a complicated
set of equations.
In particular, we have
this nonlinear term here,
which is the inertial term.
And we've already said that
we had our high Reynolds number
and turbulence results
because the inertia is
very strong compared to the
viscous term which is here.
So that's the divergence
of the viscous
or the viscous
forces on the fluid.
So these two terms we
know are important.
They have to balance and the
inertia is particularly strong
and it is what leads to the very
complicated flows that we see.
So you can solve these equations
numerically on a computer
and generate simulations that
look a lot like experiments
on turbulent jets.
What I'd like to do here is
just to derive by simple scaling
arguments what sort of the
structure of the solutions
could look like.
So these two terms,
as we just indicated,
are the ones that are most
likely to balance in the time
average flow.
So let's consider
a time averaged
steady flow which has a
velocity component of v_z
that depends on r and z.
So it's basically
something like this,
which is basically
expanding, but has
a certain sort of localization
of the flow in the middle.
And it's smooth because
we're averaging over all
the complexity of the jets.
So the jet looks something like
this with all kinds of vortices
and eddies that
are getting bigger
as it goes as you're
entraining more
and more air from the outside.
So we're going to look
at the time average flow.
And we're also going
to, importantly,
assume that we have
an eddy viscosity.
So the kinematic viscosity,
nu in the equations
as I've written them here,
represents the diffusion
momentum.
If a parcel of fluid is moving
with a certain momentum,
it has a chance of
passing that momentum
to the neighboring fluid
and moving it along with it.
And that is accomplished
through viscous stresses.
So the eddy viscosity
basically assumes
that that diffusion
process from momentum
happens at the scale of the
largest eddy in the flow.
And so we've talked about the
assumption of eddy diffusivity.
But for eddy viscosity,
what I'll write
is the eddy viscosity
is a typical velocity
which is v_z times a length
scale which is delta.
So what I'm saying
here with this
is that if I go out to a certain
position z and ask myself,
what is the sort of width
of the jet at site z,
then there's all kinds of
eddies but the largest eddy
is kind of at that scale.
And so if I write
down an eddy viscosity
it's going to be these
sort of average velocity
there are times that scale.
So that's going to
be the eddy velocity.
And I'm going to replace--
so when I do my
time averaging, I'm
going to replace the
microscopic viscosity
of the fluid,
kinematic viscosity,
with the eddy viscosity.
So that's an important
modification.
And so if I do that.
If I do this time averaging
and look at the eddy viscosity,
then I take these two
terms and balance them,
I'm going to get v_z bar,
so that's my average v_z.
I'm looking at the z
component of momentum
here of that first
Navier-Stokes equation.
And I get v_z dot derivative of
v_z with respect to z plus v_r.
And there's also an r
component of velocity.
So there is also
some velocity in fact
which is coming
in from the sides.
But I'm just going be interested
in this term here v_z dr.
And I'm going to balance this
against the eddy viscosity,
the eddy--
or nu eddy I should say, sorry,
nu eddy is eddy viscosity--
times and then the Laplacian
in is 1 r d/dr r dv_z dr. So
that's just the Laplacian in
its cylindrical coordinates.
And now I'm going to make
the assumption that this ve
scales as v bar z times delta.
And so now I'm going
to do a scaling
analysis on this equation.
And so what we see is we
have v_z over z times--
and then at least
for that first so--
I should say these
two terms will
be of comparable size
because of incompressibility--
the second equation.
I won't go through
the details of that.
And we'll just do a
scaling argument
balancing these two terms.
So if I look at v_z
divided by z times v_z
so that's a scaling
of those two terms,
I can balance that
against v_z delta times--
and the scale for r is delta.
So I have 1/delta
for the 1/r,
1/delta for
the derivative times
delta * (1/delta) * v_z.
So there's a lot there.
But notice the v_z's all cancel.
And we're left with a
bunch of deltas here.
And how many, because
of the eddy viscosity,
we are left with--
all of this is
just 1 over delta.
This is 1 over z.
And so we find here
the delta scales as z.
So in other words, we
have a conical shape.
So the boundary
of their thickness
is a constant times z.
And what we write is that
delta is equal to alpha z
specifically.
And we define the turbulent
entrainment coefficient alpha
that way.
And then once we've
done that, we've
already shown that
from the momentum flux
that v_z scales as the square
root of k/rho_air
times 1 over delta.
So this basically now gives
me the scaling of the problem.
In fact, there is a
similarity solution
for the shape this profile
that one could solve for.
And it has the form
that, for example, the v_z
is square root of--
because delta is
proportional to z.
So it's the square
root of k over rho
a z times some function
of r over alpha z.
And then there's a
similar expression
for the other
velocity component.
And the function F looks very
much as I've sketched here.
It's essentially a Gaussian
type profile or a bell curve
that kind of localizes the
velocity across this distance
delta.
The second thing that
we're interested in
is the mean concentration.
And that would be a
concentration of, let's say,
virions contained in
infectious aerosol droplets.
So there's a mean
concentration profile
in the jet assuming
that we're injecting
a fluid of a constant
concentration
at the source of the jet.
So again, we can do some
scaling arguments here.
So if we ask ourselves,
what is the mass flow
rate through a slice or actually
the volumetric flow rate,
use me, that is what is called a
Q and it'll just be an average.
This will be the
average velocity
times the cross-sectional
area at a given position.
So this is scaling like--
so area scaled is
like delta squared.
And then the velocity scales
in this way is 1 over delta.
So this ends up scaling as k
over rho a times just delta.
So the volumetric flow
rate is increasing
with r and that's a sign that we
are actually in training fluid
as I indicated.
This is not just the
fluid we're injecting
but it's moving forward and
it's sucking more fluid in.
And all that fluid
is kind of becoming
part of the turbulent
jet as it grows.
Now if we ask-- so this is
our flow rate, volumetric flow
rate, but we can
also ask ourselves,
what is the flux
of concentration
of virions per unit volume.
Well, that would be the
average concentration
times the average flow
rate because flow rate
is volume per time
and concentration
is number per volume.
So this is a total
number per time.
And this we will assume
should be a constant
because as you can
see from this picture,
if we're injecting a bunch
of concentration of let's say
droplets here, they will spread
out in the turbulent flow
but they don't really have
a good mechanism to get out
of the turbulent flow.
The turbulent flow is
sucking fluid into the plume
and so the particles
are just kind of well
mixed in that plume and we
could assume they have a roughly
constant concentration.
And so, if that's the case,
and in fact, this constant
would be lambda Q if we're
thinking of, for example,
infect--
c is the concentration
infection quanta.
Then lambda Q is the rate of
admission of infection quanta
from the mouth.
We've already talked
about that quantity.
And this is now telling me how
the concentration infection
quanta decays with time.
And so we find if
we substitute now
is that the concentration
infection quanta at a position
z scales as so I have
to divide by Q so I
get the inverse of this.
So I get square root
of rho a over k.
And then I have
lambda Q over alpha z.
So this tells me that if I
plot as a function of distance
from the mouth in the
direction of the jet,
the concentration
of infection quanta
that are carried by virions
in aerosol droplets,
then somewhere here I have,
let's say, at z equals 0,
is the mouth where I'm exhaling.
And the concentration
there is actually cQ.
In fact that is
something we've talked
about before, which is that's
the key disease parameter--
the concentration of infection
quanta in the exhaled breath
of an infected person.
So we know at the mouth,
that's what we start with.
And what the turbulent
theory is telling us
is how that concentration
is decaying with time
and is decaying like 1 over z.
And so that tells us sort of
our relative risk of infection
in different positions relative
to being mouth to mouth
with the infected person.